but i can affect the standard of living
that people i grew up with i can expect
to
make sure the standard of living people
i grew up with this
incoherent old daughter history will
judge him by how much he grew the
government
not how well the economy did under his
term so what is the actual agenda here
the actual agenda of course
is to grow the government right if you
can continue to promote the idea
that america is in a state of crisis and
that everybody has to mask up
and that nobody's going back to work
then you can continue to promote these
giant government programs so democrats
right now are continuing to promote the
idea of a national
eviction moratorium okay here's the deal
america's unemployment rate is down back
to like six percent
it is we're adding jobs hand over foot
the only reason
handover fist the only reason why we
have not added more jobs is because we
have paid people to stay home
right now small businesses are having
trouble getting people to actually come
in and work
because there are so many people who are
making more money by being on
unemployment
okay so the job but democrats don't want
to accept that we are back in an upward
economic swing
number one because they want to take
credit for it with stimulus that has not
yet even gone out
and number two because they want to
promote the idea that the pandemic
continues so they can continue to ram
through trillions upon trillions of
dollars
in spending so let's be real about this
in the first place the federal
government did not have the ability to
simply declare via executive fiat and
eviction moratorium
the cdc does not have the power to
simply declare across the nation
the center for disease control are the
center for rent like what
where's the empowering legislation that
allows the cdc to decide that you no
longer have to pay rent
and by the way who exactly compensates
the landlords you know you talk about
these housing shortages in america's
major cities it turns out
when you deprive landlords of rent for
like a year the predictable response is
i'm not going to
build any more buildings and rent them
out you end up with more of a shortage
like rent control
the more you prevent the free market
from having its way the more you prevent
supply from meeting demand
okay in any case a federal judge in
washington dc on wednesday according to
the washington post ruled that the
center for disease control and
prevention overstepped its legal
authority by issuing a nationwide
eviction moratorium
a ruling that could affect millions of
struggling americans well
yeah but that's not the que like if
congress wants to pass an eviction
moratorium
they can go ahead and try first of all i
think that's probably unconstitutional
it violates the
the freedom of contract that is inherent
in in freedom of association in the
united states but
since we long ago gave up on anything
like limited government
i suppose that you could try to pass
that via congress the idea that the cdc
unilaterally gets to decide that you
don't have to pay a rent anymore is an
absurdity on its face
the order says it is the role of the
political branches and not the courts to
assess the merits of policy measures
designed to combat the spread of disease
even during a global pandemic the
question for the court is the narrow one
does the public health service act grant
the cdc the legal authority to impose a
nationwide eviction moratorium
it does not the biden administration
says it will appeal the decision
so here's the thing why what's the end
of the pandemic what are you appealing
the ruling does not affect state or
local eviction moratoriums in washington
dc for example the city government's ban
on all evictions
remains in place landlords and property
owners have consistently challenged the
cdc order
arguing the policy sets an undue
financial burden on business owners yeah
you think
it turns out that if you run an
apartment complex and you can't evict
anybody for not paying their bills
you're the one who ends up footing the
bill for that
okay and they want to continue this like
indefinitely they want to continue these
eviction
the question at this point is not even
the legal authority to do this the
question at this point is
why are you even pushing eviction
moratoriums when we are at the end of
the pandemic
and the answer is they want a forever
pandemic folks on the democratic side of
the aisle want a forever pandemic
because
every crisis is an opportunity so we're
going to promote bad
scientific standards with regard to the
with regard to covid
we are going to promote endless spending
because covet is still a crisis right
this is why you have the entire
democratic party
still promoting the idea that we need to
spend tons and tons and tons of money
on infrastructure okay let's be straight
about this the united states does not
have a major infrastructure problem the
brookings institute
says and has been saying for years the
united states our infrastructure is
actually in pretty good shape this ain't
about infrastructure
it's about everything if you can call it
infrastructure it becomes infrastructure
here is co-president harris yesterday
suggesting that infrastructure is child
care
i'd like to hear from each of you as
though you are talking to the people in
washington dc
to explain why
child care is part of infrastructure and
let me just tell you the way i define
infrastructure one of my definitions
is the things you just need to get where
you need to go
so let's talk about why child
care is a part of that
i define infrastructure as anything i
want anytime i want it
so let's talk about why free ice cream
is infrastructure
okay this is why they need the pandemic
because otherwise everybody would look
at this and go are you insane
healthcare is not infrastructure you
want to do something on healthcare try
it
you want to call it infrastructure
you're out of your damn mind
but the entire democratic party is into
this because of course they don't care
about deficits
alexander ocasio-cortez she's out there
this is this genius this economic genius
democrat twitch she says but you know
we keep worrying about deficits why are
we even worrying about deficits i mean
i've never had to actually meet a
payroll but
sure i know how to spend your money i
don't think that the deficit is the most
important
thing in upon which we should be
hinging the our infrastructure and jobs
plan on
i think um it's not the deficit it's
things like employment it's things like
our
poverty rate in the united states or
rather unemployment as well
it's we should be pegging this to
the actual material circumstances
that we want to measure ourselves
against
in improving people's lot uh in this
country that's a long way of saying i
don't want to pay for anything because i
don't need to pay for anything because
i've never paid for anything
so that's a really easy way of doing
that really well done right there
joe biden also defending his massive
spending plans in his typically
incoherent fashion
everything i'm proposing
that be done to generate economic growth
employment
and put us in a position where we can
out-compete any other country in the
world with research and development
and moving ahead um i pay for
we talk about i love we talk about how
this is going to cost so much money i'm
not paying for it
i mean he's a joke by the way he says
he's pushing higher taxes
the language he uses with regard to
higher taxes is so patently crazy
he says things like well you know i'm
just you know those rich people
they just don't need that second and
third house first of all talk to bernie
he seems to like that lake house an
awful lot you seem to like your multiple
houses an awful lot mr president
but beyond that that's not the question
the question is whether you confiscate
wealth from the people who have
typically created jobs and hand handed
to a bunch of dufy
over at the federal government to decide
how exactly to disseminate that wealth
in the most inefficient possible fashion
or whether you allow the economy to grow
but for him it's all about confiscation
of wealth the real motivating factor
here is that joe biden wants to go down
in history as not an inconsequential
figure that's all
joe biden knows he's a one-term guy he's
clearly a one-time guy
and because he's a one-term guy he wants
to just push everything through
right now and he's got the pandemic to
bank on and that pandemic is on the way
and it's pretty much at the end of it i
mean we know we all know this
contra anthony fauci who says we're in
the bottom of the six which is just nuts
we are nearing the end of this thing and
everyone is aware of this
joe biden is using that as the basis for
the argument
that we are just going to penalize
because he knows then the beautiful
thing about being a democrat is you can
be the crappiest president ever you can
be just garbage and they will continue
to to laud you
as an amazingly transformational figure
so long as you grew the government it
doesn't matter that fdr's
programs expanded the great depression
into a decade-long event
it does not matter because he grew the
government it doesn't matter that lbj's
economic program
took a very strong economy circle like
1963-1964 and proceeded to transform it
into a stagnating government a
stagnating economy
all the way from 1967 essentially to
1981.
okay that's okay because he grew the
government joe biden knows the same he
knows that history will judge him by how
much he grew the government
not how well the economy did under his
term right because
if you think of historic american
democratic presidents nobody thinks of
bill clinton
even though the economy did great under
bill clinton everybody thinks instead
of who grew the government most joe
biden knows this and that's why he's
pushing this nonsense and that's also
why he's pushing his
class warrior nonsense pretty ironic
stuff from a guy who allowed his son to
run around
the globe picking up bags of cash using
his last name
we're not going to deprive these
executives their second or third home
travel privately by jet that's not going
to affect your standard living at all
not a little tiny bit
but i can affect the standard of living
that people i grew up with
if they have a job i can expect to
make sure the standard of living people
i grew up with
child care can afford it so 20 million
women can be back in the workforce
i can affect the standard relationship
with the amount of gym i grew up with
this incoherent old daughter talking
about how
you know if he confiscates wealth from
the wealthy and then he gives it to
people at the other end of the spectrum
this is going to create jobs
yeah you know they've tried this in many
many places it does not create economic
growth it is a dumb
idea it has been disproved every time it
has been tried but you need the pandemic
in order to push this sort of stuff
you need it because if we went right
back to that three percent unemployment
rate we had under trump
everybody recognizes you don't need to
do what the democrats are talking about
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe